يعني الوزير تحدث على موضوع همم وزير
التعليم العالي في طالبان اا قبل ايام
للوزير دعوه وزير التعليم العالي في
طالبان الى مناظره بخصوص المناهج الدراسيه
وتعليم المراه من الذي دعا اخر مره قاسم
حليمي
ضيف طلب مناظره وزير التعليم الذي اخذ
قرار
على الكلام الوزير لانه وزير التعليم
العالي تحدث عن موضوع السفر بدون محرم
البقاء في المساكن هم الان همم هو نفسه
وزيره التعليم العالي اسره ما زالت خارج
افغانستان هو نفس الوزير نعم
وانت لا تسمح لي امراه افغانيه تدرس في
الجامع المساكن الطالبات ليست مختلطه وهي
ساكن خاصه بالطالبات
تحدث الرسمي هو رئيس المكتب السياسي بناته
خصنا في الخارج صحيح لماذا لم يطبق هذا
المعايير على نفسه يعني هنا الازدواجيه في
ان طالبان يريدون الخير لانفسهم ولا
يريدون الخير لكن سافوا الانسان ويفرضون
اديولوجيا وافكارهم المتطرفه على النساء
في افغانستان